I'm Sebastian.
I work for Football Addicts,
An application company based in Gothenburg, Sweden.
We launched two years ago
Forza Football is called.
It is a consumer application for football.
You can follow your favorite teams and patrols
all over the world.
This is my small agenda,
I will move between the challenges
Which we encountered during the design we changed.
I will then give you some examples
Of the different views to apply before the transfer
To and after multidimensional design.
Well, this is our application,
This was a form of almost a year,
It's a list of matches.
Where you can see all the games that interest you,
It's a very dedicated experience but it's very complicated now.
The largest part of the transport process is the multidimensional design
In the overview.
I think it's a bit hard,
Find results that
Would like to get it from this offer.
It is really hard to get a quick look
On small things, this was
Is what we wanted to change.
Mobility is very important in any application
But we have a lot of content, lots of data and information.
So access to the information you seek
Is important, really important.
So we wanted to get rid of the stacked list.
We have had a side menu for a long time,
Then we felt that we needed to update mobility
Make it smoother and easier to understand.
If you click on what you want, you'll get it right away.
Touch content,
It's important to show the content you're interested in
On the right when using the application.
Well, these are some different screens
Which we had before redesigned.
In the middle here is the team page.
I think it's really hard to -
We created copies of different types of criteria
the design.
Here you can see two of them.
Here we have a switch button inspired by the IOS operating system
I think it is inappropriate.
We have different colors,
We used something like colors to emphasize things
But I do not really know what that meant.
Well, here is the image of the league
With knowledge and everything else.
We wanted to provide a more consistent experience,
This is what we have reached after redesign.
We recognize that this work is still going on,
The redesign work never ends.
Well, we can always improve the application,
But if we focus on the match list,
We strive to make every game appear as important.
As football fans care about the results,
The results must capture attention here.
We tried to reduce the size - we tried to make
Mobility is more stressed.
The appearance of the stacked menu,
Well, we tried everything
Easier to understand and does not hinder you.
And also the pages of teams and periodicals
It's moving now and you can pass it away
If you no longer care.
So it's like dealing with paper pages here,
As well as minimizing the toolbar.
I can place an animation here if you're familiar with Google spreadsheets,
But, I think you understand my intent.
We showed a certain amount of basic content
And basic information about each team.
Thus we have created card-shaped views of everything you think
As important.
However, the main part of the equation,
Is of course what users think is important.
So we need to test this design maybe to trigger some views
The cards are up or down.
What I said, however, is that work is continuing,
We try to use tests as much as possible,
We have just started the AVA test
And things like that.
It is a new subject for us,
But I really admire what
Google is now on design libraries and more.
For example, it took this slide and clicked the toolbar
Two or three months of work
As I remember.
But now can be implemented with a five-line code
Through the new design library.
So thank Google, although this I missed,
Yeah.
I have finished.